quick rundown 1-minute warzone rated
everything is pretty much the same 74 or
75 players 1790 average rating time
handicapped once again it will be
adjusted the times according to ratings
in order to try to even things out here
we go 30 minutes of chess play fast and
went fast let's go they're not pairing
me up what's going on here Oh No am I
the only one that's not being paired up
test I'm still online oh man what's
happening
come on pammi up oh I did enter I forgot
to enter you fool here we go oh I didn't
even enter the time oh there yelling at
me the twitch at those seconds are gonna
be precious I tell you I was only gonna
be a spectator for that one what a
blunder there's no way I can win i
blundered it in the under enter button
okay let's go you got a lot of homework
to do cuz you are being silly here okay
is my rook dead might be dead no I got
this
it's very scary though no I need back
rank defense
you wanna start I tell you not a way you
want to start take that get your pieces
here in here I'm gonna lose stuff no no
no you can't get that pun let's do this
it looks really stupid but I'm gonna do
it
my King needs to play I'm gonna get cut
off though okay no I'm not okay
I could easily round a little bit
that Bishop out of there it's got to go
you got to go Bishop no I don't want my
pond to be fixed on a dark square huh oh
this is scary this is very scary yes I
got the rook give me the rope give me
the rope give me the rope give me the
rope how much time do I have
okay is everything all right okay okay
the bishop can't move so the King has to
move eventually and then they make
progress yes make progress I'm gonna
come over here get that pond and then
everything should be squeaky clean
Ron pond run defense no come on over
here I should just move that pond what
am i doing check let's go over here pop
push how much time I'd have a lot more
time man I'm afraid to see how many
games have been won already by people by
people just playing here we go Oh 12
five four three games in Wow
what a blunder to start I didn't hit the
enter button oh there are so many chat
messages coming in on Twitch hit the
enter button you stupid idiot you have
to enter in order to play man what a
blunder blunder time oh is that gonna
cost me watch I'll need those extra 50
seconds of course it's castle before
it's too late
oh right here I could also do that now
let's support here first I'm going after
the the jugular jugular grab the pond
ooh and then between ER you got to watch
out for those tweeners right there
grab a knight grab a pond go for the
King kill the King Queen d3 coming up
Queen d3 looking for me mating - or
something close to it
something close do it yes a matin one -
Megan - even if the pond pushes check me
come on resignation these are precious
seconds there we go back to termina
could've also went to the corner 12 12 9
6 what do I have why are these two
highlighted they're highlighting the
cheese Network the cheese Network versus
me okay let's see what kind of holes are
gonna be in this cheese right here man I
tell you what this has to stop I can't
keep them I can't keep doing this okay
kill the night kill him dead let's go I
could throw in a check in between er
watch out for the killer in-betweener
dark squares check its from home kill
this pond bishop here no matter what
check okay I gotta watch out for this
square this is very scary
Queen trade kill this night no no no no
no I like I like having that night right
there he's okay okay rook trade and then
hit this bishop and then get in b5
you're gonna be fine I should probably
take that beep on let me at the bishop
first stay active rook you know you want
to stay active hit the Bishop b5
incoming I got the bishop
checkmate soon d5 is still on the agenda
may move Knight no I want to keep my
rook active move Knight move Knight I'm
gonna force them to move yes mate black
come on go go go go go go go go go
if I say fast enough it'll happen 2000
2017 12 okay
oh I fall to fell back again this guy is
having a good tournament I gotta fight
back timewise here without a doubt
French window
and okay well calm or territory Fort
Knox defense Fort Knox variation all
right let's go all right take some
pieces might be a pin if the night takes
here it could be trouble I'm on b7 okay
this is getting uh quiet quiet territory
ooh that was almost a bad slip might
have an end game territory let's go
let's go I need a I need what what do I
need I should have done that okay this
is not good I got to do what what do you
have to do one pair of Brooks needs to
go even if they undone
okay and my King needs to come up and
okay he's up and now this pawn needs to
do something timewise I need to support
this a little bit more King to f5 and
now what all right here oh this is scary
actually have a plan I have a plan I
think it might work let's give this
check and then somehow get this pawn
here let's give another check this is no
good
it's no good no good I'm gonna try and
be a pest though I'm gonna try my best
to be a pest go ahead take that pawn
I want this guy right here and now run
pawn no no right here right here and can
i lock can it be captured it could be
captured right here is this working good
Oh what am i doing what am i doing what
am i doing okay is this working I got a
check I got to come over here and here
push cut the King off
I gotta come over here give a check on
behind it
free moves pre moves more pre moves how
much time how much time you can't move
like that your King o 42:39 they lost in
time okay D crusher he was playing in
the last tournament here we go ah okay
mmm all right I have a center I have a
big center let's do this before it's oh
it's gonna be lost
okay let me tell how I got to work
myself into a pin there is no Knight g5
fortunately so now I could just Castle
actually let me stop that night ah
sneaky I don't want a castle now I want
to keep the H file for my rook and I
want to get out of this pin oh now that
is scary they didn't grab that pawn
though let's do this my rip wants to
play here we go oh I better get over
here before it's to hell I'm in a killer
pin night right here soon although
there's Forks and stuff there's silly
forks that's what to check though okay
is this gonna be alright I'm on the
night okay I have stuff defended now
that Bishop needs to get out of here
what a pain let's go hear that Bishop
needs to get out of here right here pawn
push know that pawns gonna find you need
to maintain this point though otherwise
my light squares go there's a big
trouble I'm up a rook ooh a little scary
a little scary or a lot scary maybe rook
right here and everything is okay no no
no no no hanging them do this and then
double okay I got to break that open
break this up break it up no mates check
that's a little scary okay I'm looking
for check and then mate next just Queen
trade though clean trade and Primos we
run the King right up and look for me
it's coming in around this way there's
you're gonna defend my bishop is there
to defend okay now it's this and then
this leading to mate
okay back to tournament third off fifty
six forty six forty thirty seven thirty
six thirty one thirty ah okay you can do
this come on you could do this
let's go f7 I need some quick kills I'm
getting zero quick kills here we go
Knight g5 soon and then Queen out its
Castle first I guess that's not gonna
happen
take my knight I should take here now
the knight needs to take otherwise I get
this okay f7 also Queen here this could
be a killer killer take the rook
discover checks coming up I got the rook
for free oh come on they got my what so
I'm on the Queen and then Bishop here I
guess I got to watch out for that night
it's tricky Knight just take there and
then get out of this check beat bow ok
I'm not chopping that pawn push there we
go that's that's the plan pawn push or
that tonight is a little bit scary here
and I'm in checking distance let's do
this I got the clean this is a
resignation time come on I got the Queen
with check this is leading to me very
very soon I'm not resigning
don't run away they're running away
does that make close to it this mate
close to it
then that's gonna block the Kings gonna
flee he's fleeing is this me yes back to
tournament 90 how do you overcome 90 oh
man there's a lot of big ones up here 70
I'm at 42 even if I even if I enter it
on time even if I enter it on time how
do you come back from this let's go
d3 incoming and let me point my bishop
here and chase this guy around a little
bit all right now what do we want I
don't care about my dark square Bishop
and shattered structure do I care about
that maybe okay f4 is where I want to be
oh this is a nice one very good nice
shot
excellent well done fantastic and grab
this pawn I have that covered
now what King up should grab another
pawn defend Queen let me just push here
to get a passed pawn my king is scared
it's very scared
I should have let's go Queen f6 grab
this pawn mate mate on g7 or g2 no let's
go here I want mate still me coming up
resignation what's going on g2 yes mate
doctor tournament 110 97 91 56 Oh talk
about a mountain having to climb a
mountain here three games out 15 minutes
and change left okay
so there's still a little more than half
left here well more than half left and
let's go
f5 incoming let's go
typical Grand Prix attack land Bishop h6
I want to get that in in Knight to g5
this Knight probably shouldn't take care
you take here but then I have rook up
and over stuff rook up and over is
another thing I could be running with
let's take their first and then oh okay
they're giving me that this and then
double up rooks rook to h3 maybe even a
pawn push in some instances I like the
rook to h3 though if the knight defends
a Kansan it's unreliable really let me
do this first and then rook here
something with the pawn push as well Oh
check okay I'm gonna have to be content
with this there's no there's no attacker
actually maybe there is or maybe there's
not
or maybe there is maybe there isn't
gotta go for the time though you got to
be a clock burner burn the clock when in
doubt burn the clock each five let's
chop that up oh I'm on f7 ooh that one's
gotta sting a little bit my king is uh
scared though oh he's very scared run
okay there's no time for my opponent to
do anything though run over here don't
get made it back to tournament the
forefront of time 141 1197 72 I'm
looking for top three it seems ah man
that's a lot of games that have been in
so far how many did I play not enough
not enough games in and not enough games
one get rid of the night so I can
increase my control over these dark
squares I want to get in b5 I want to
watch out for the e5 advance I'm looking
to play on the Queen side a6 b5 rook b8
let's stop ePHI first stop my opponents
plan in this Bishop has to move before
that F pawn contributes so alright
Bishop back I'm not sure what I do if
the bishop goes back to
- but they're not going back to e - so I
have this in and now my rook springs to
life if the knight isn't captured it
posts up right here B - a lot of
pressure
I'm gonna keep my knight around rook to
b3 rook takes pawn also is on the cards
the knight is in a pin my knight could
play here my queen could go to b6 and I
just want to triple up triple up Queen
to b6 here we go and right here three
pieces are hitting this it's difficult
to defend very very difficult ton of
pressure on the Queen side and now I
have enough on it so this isn't a quick
kill but it's it's still a winning
position right here my knight is in a
really really good spot and I just want
to get in Oh dark Square weaknesses
right here I should have maybe
considered g5 okay my Knights are gonna
be able to land some fork soon I would
think let's do this I want to get the
dark squares we can f4 okay I guess Oh
take this oh okay wait I have what let's
check this bishop check they don't have
any time so just do anything anything
any move don't let your clock tick okay
back to tournament 91 60 13 games in
twelve ten nine nine nine okay let's do
this here where are the quick wins
they're nowhere to be found
okay take this and then okay I guess
you're gonna go with this so this is a
complete lockdown I've played this in a
five minute game if those of you have
seen the five minute fanatics tournament
this is a similar structure to that okay
let's maybe do what well stir my center
here and then looking for mates
oh man just take the night take the
night take the night yes me back to term
at 110 160 131 110 I took over a third
place guy come on can I get second and
second what I should be shooting for 10
minutes and change let's go here just
give up the sea pond oh I didn't want to
do that let's do this
treat it as a gambit okay I get it back
take yes my queen has a good spot right
here
ooh what do we have here what's going on
Queen here looking for my what's
happening with that move come on oh I
have the Queen I want to hang on to this
stuff I want to look for me
Bishop pin we got the knight now this is
a mating or close to it very very close
to it the king of the King has to play
here the bishop could block and make it
one threat you just chase the Queen away
and then what the Queen I guess could go
there looking for this Knight check on
this square okay looking for making one
something really really close to it oh
that's me back to tournament 130 180 180
uh what I'm out in 180 151 130 14 games
in top player has three more games in
than myself okay okay what is going on
here what is this kind of setup here my
Knights gonna get kicked away towards
this side of the board I have a ton of
development here just looking to open it
up and I'm going to avoid the Queen
exchange open it up and also this
diagonal for my bishop maybe even the
file so I have this opened up I want to
chase the night away next and then get
to g6 check where's the King gonna go
open this up Knight to e4 and then I
okay I'm the bishop I want to get this
in right here there's got to be some me
something soon
this check is another check with my
Knights let's make sure I just get that
rook and I got a I got a do oh I just
dropped my knight
okay just take this pawn maybe I get the
B file give me the B file no it'll be
file I have this Bishop takes pawn is
available with check it's still
available with check okay they didn't
they didn't want that how much time I
don't have too much time here pawn push
open it up just a little bit more I
gotta watch out for g2 okay c6 I'm on
the Queen resignation let's not do that
to give a check I'm on the bishop to
take the bishop now I'm looking for maid
where is that me okay back to tournament
they resigned 201 71 150 15 4 they have
15 games in 14 games I have 12 in where
are the quick resign errs Blumenfeld
gambit okay I have the rook this
happened once before the diagonals open
it's week resignation come on just
resigned just resigned just resigned
we're both even on time and there's no
compensation right oh I got a free rook
let's run home before you're trapped
come on quick kill pre-move oh that
pawns gonna push okay now what yep there
it is okay so no quick kills
dark squares dark squares dark squares
now what my Knights connected pawn push
Queen checks I got the night come on
this is dead you know it's dead H pun
okay gotta kick that night away thorn
open it up open it up I'm on the rock
I'm on the night queenside castle okay
they resigned back to term at 172 2171
176 minutes and change
whoo could I get paired up with the top
guy if I could win then I would go up
maybe 20 and they'd go back two points
that could happen I don't know how
likely it is but it definitely could
happen and I'm gonna be losing stuff the
night's gonna play here okay I think
that could have been very annoying
let's stop this advance and stop it
again and let's hawk the McQueen's
watching over this now oh they missed it
they missed that detail I'm gonna do an
in-betweener Knight takes pawn first
okay back to tournament one ninety two
twenty two twenty one ninety one seventy
one I'm in second I mention my way up
I'm not I'm going down swinging I'm
going down swinging I all I could I just
need them an in-betweener or not an
in-betweener I'm tongue tied again I
need a quick resigner too many words
that end with er that's my problem
okay let's go pressure on d4 that's what
you want to do in the French that's
exactly what you want to do in the
French okay get rid of the bad guys oh I
didn't want to do it like that but yeah
definitely didn't want to do like that
so what do you do what do you do now
that you goofed up and you're king can't
castle he's not too happy about things
less than 40 oh okay let's go let's go
let's go you can do it get rid of a
knight and get to c4 or something I just
want my Knights connected can we have
that please soon Oh before it's too late
let's get that night out there I have to
take here and I want a queen trade
please let's just trade Queens please I
don't want to take that beet pond no way
that's crazy take the Queen and then
it's okay this pond is overextended
big time I'm doing this to just stop the
knight from getting here okay I'll still
go with this I'll still be okay with
this it's uh I got to get this up I
should have done it sooner pawn push I
want my night to get to d5 we're eight
maybe even my king as a position
simplifies a bit more the bishop
cooked now cooked Bishop recapture with
my night looking for Forks somehow or
checks Forks and checks they have less
than 10 just move anything anything
anything I don't want my time to burn
just throw a check so this is a little
scary a little scary just run away
you're not getting made it are you okay
back to tournament to 10 to 40 to 10
okay
17 games in I fifteen four minutes and
change 30 points is too much to overcome
can I get in two more games this next
game has to be against that top guy if I
have any chance if I have any chance but
I think that tough guy is ready to win
his game fishing poles where's the
fishing pole when you need it here we go
open up this file gonna go queenside
open it up oh I wasn't expecting that
one I'm on the Queen resignation come on
you lost your Queen resign uh-huh come
on you lost your queen come on you know
you want to resign
you lost a minor piece let's go man
now what mates over here get to UM c7 c7
is where I want to be really really soon
check check check
they resigned back to chairman to 802
8230
come on okay can I cure second place at
least second place okay I shouldn't have
went with this I need something more
dynamic this is not dynamic enough okay
I'm gonna try for something here make it
huh
just no use doing that now and get my
Knight to c4 No
let's get this a five move in Oh
actually yeah let's go over here Knight
b6 to c4 I have to watch out for f7 a
little bit okay let's go here now
light-square move move move move and now
let me do this pawn push okay open
things up here and then I'm at Bishop f5
f4 stuff this is a good idea I think the
night might pivot go here there's night
there my queen is close to being trapped
whoa
that was really really close to being
trapped and now we're gonna have a clean
trade shut that Bishop down there's back
rank mates for as long as the bishop is
on that square I'm dropping this pawn
okay now what mate move Knight capture
here I'm on this pond come on mate
one minute 19 back determine 300 I just
want to stay ahead of 241 can I get
second it's fight for second here 110
left 110 which means I have to oh I have
to go to the gambit go for this and what
next pawn push I got this Knight
I have to move I have to finish the game
in like six seconds if I want to be
assured to win I got the Queen come on
this is resignation time I'm on the rook
I have everything come inside castle
which is mate close to it what is this
what's going on here how much time is
left
um check is that working out how much
time 27 where we got timewise where's
the mate where's the mate this is mate
soon to it that back to term at 270 300
270 15 seconds left
I can't catch that guy that guy can
catch me though if he wins again quick
resigner
quick resign scholars me go for the
scholars made three to one they resigned
back to tournament 280 oh I still
couldn't catch second place oh they're
making me play this game get this thing
out of here is this why what's happening
here do I actually stuff to play this
game through what is this some glitch
it's not enough make me play another
game what's happening here is this yeah
this is a tournament yet this is I don't
want to play am I gonna get some points
if I win
is this gonna turn out to be a
buzzer-beater or something looking for
the buzzer-beaters here we go oh should
be scared be very scared I could maybe
still get first I'm not gonna get any
points for this this is just a glitch a
glitch aru ski and Knight takes pawn I
should have done that was stupid makin
making one or two something close to it
check no it's not happening
check again grab a knight uh what's
happening did I my rook okay let's just
see what happens here let's just see the
Knights gonna be there that's a nice
square let me give a check okay and then
what they're not calling it
know what now oh there's nitrite here
that would be a good one this it seems
like it's close to me really really
close to me okay let's just see if I get
points am I still gonna get points let's
see okay what do we got here they
resigned I got 300 they gave me points
oh no wait it showed 300 but it actually
didn't register here I got a little
excited right there man
good games